it was indeed but you actually played a
game against Ian which lasted so so long
seven and a half
hours 136 moves first things first how
were you feeling after that marathon
when you played against him I feel good
I was ready to I was ready to play more
yeah because that's because that was the
key breakthrough that was uh the moment
I've been waiting for for the first six
games of of of that match and I remember
like I was so conf um so focused for the
last two 2 and a half hours I was
playing with fairly little time on my
clock but I knew like this is my chance
like if I win if I win this game I'm
probably winning Another World
Championship so I knew that that was my
moment and uh afterwards I was just so
calm and yeah I even told uh like my M
draft are like yeah I was ready to go
like three more hours if if I needed to
I was I was going to get that win